a
[Musique]
mis
la vie c'est tout con quand est
astucieux belle
cette solution le plus sérieux
[Musique]
de vouloir devenir amies
abby c'est incroyable de ma valise là tu
vois je vois mon image n ya plus rien
qu'est ce qu'on a et on met tous
transportés qu'est ce que c'est mais
qu'est-ce qui avait là-dedans accorde de
plus j'avais des chenilles
témoin laisse le 30 est-ce que tu lui
c'est par ici tout le monde connaît un
incroyable et de mauvaise humeur
aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas joli ça
c'est pas beau on va quand même dire
bonjour aux gens pic en bouche
bonjour à tous et à toutes tu peux
somalie qu'est-ce que tu es désagréable
aujourd'hui vraiment je vais faire le
jeu de géographie tu sais mais c'est
suis pas content après toi vraiment je
te le dis tout de suite derrière les del
veille c'est désagréable
voilà
je rappelle trois éléments un pays à
découvrir avec la carte géographique le
drapeau et bonjour dans la langue du
pays derrière les del veille oui
l'edelweiss essaye de te rattraper
méchante animal
c'est un pays d'un grand pays ça
c'est un grand pays sera au juste une
haie m'inquiète un peu c'est ces deux
points noirs la france at il crié deux
capitales sur ce pays au point de
capital dans ce pays on n'a qu'une seule
enfin nous allons voir ça tout à leurs
gardes dakar n'ont pas la carte il me
semble que j'ai trouvé tout de même
c'est assez qu'est ce que c'est beau
comme pays bas c'est un beau pays est un
très grand pays très très très très très
très grand 1 voici le drapeau du pays
le voilà y flotte comment il flotte même
nom il flotte le drapeau flotte a mis le
drapeau flotte oui ça c'est le c'est
l'emblème du pays ça je pense que ça
doit vous aider regardez bien ça c'est
une feuille telle une feuille d'érable
comme les lapins si tu veux râble de
lapin c'est amusant c'est tout cuit les
fier de toi oh là là là là là
et c'est un pays où l'on parle à la fois
le français et l'anglais puisque vous le
voyez on dit good morning mais on dit
aussi
bonjour bon tenir bon jambon beurre ou
alors vous avez découvert de quel pays
il s'agit ça doit mettre sur l'érable
dont la voix il s'agit du canada le
canada qui a comme capitale ottawa alors
là je pense qu'il s'agit des
emplacements de deux des principales
villes du pays probablement montréal ici
et toronto ici près du lac voilà la
mélasse la capitale la capitelle c'est
ottawa c'est pas la même allez je vais
dans le jardin il n'a pas tort ah ouais
je n'ai pas avec moi les choses qui
m'amusent je le prends avec moi oui tu
aurais une tirelire nos jardins oui bien
entendu allez à tout de suite tout
content et hd
lalalala j'te jure non piquée clients
pensent ils du coup sur coup
puis je connais d'autres points communs
alors vous le savez mais bien sûr
fiscaux alors favori dans son prix tu
peux rien oui oui voilà j'arrive
j'arrive j'arrive jeu arrive les enfants
j'arrive pas d'affolement bruit les
portes se referment ça va alors à ce
qu'elle soit vite parce que c'est
difficile pas si c'est difficile alors
moi je suis pas prêt du tout je suis je
suis je n'ai pas envie de chercher de
façon difficile j'espère que nous avions
vont m'aider parce que moi je la
dernière fois vous m'avez vu avec ce jeu
là de vichy quotas
alors quand qu'est-ce que tu es toi
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et ben moi je ne
peux pas vous citer tous les endroits
dans lesquels on ne trouve pas ce que tu
en as trop faut dire que je ne suis pas
difficile à fabriquer un jeu peut être
en bois en faire un carton on peut me
dessiner avec un crayon découpé avec une
paire de ciseaux tiens tiens on peut
même tracé sur le sable je peux même
exister dans l'eau kia ou plutôt sur
l'eau c'est même ça qui est le plus
amusant et alors ça non plus c'est pas
difficile à faire tu vois tu te mets au
bord d'une rivière tu ou sur un pont tu
lances un caillou dans l'eau et hop ça y
est j'existe pâte à l'exil voilà oui oui
ça commence à venir oui fès bell bell
moi je suis un objet très précis or je
ne suis pas un objet de luxe mais je
suis bien utile pour ceux qui comme moi
aime bien que les choses soient bien
rangés dans une maison sur nous arrange
pas sa brosse à dents ces chaussures
c'est libre tout le monde se dispute par
exemple quand on se met à table je
n'aime pas que chacun ils disent c'est
ma serviette non c'est pas la tienne moi
je la pluie comme ça non c'est pas vrai
si c'est beau mais c'est dément non pour
éviter ce genre de discussions on a
inventé et grâce à moi chacun retrouve
sa serviette sans erreur possible
bah j'ai l'impression d'avoir à peu près
trouver belles belles mais je
préférerais avoir la version de poche
moussu pour être tout à fait sûre
et ben moi moi aujourd'hui ce que je
suis je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si je
vais oser le dire ci dit le alors alors
arqués je ne suis pas un gros mot ah non
non non mais je crois que c'est un mot
enfin un peu familier on remarque bien
que je l' ai souvent entendu employés ça
tiens par exemple l'autre jour par des
petits garçons qui voulait entrer dans
une boutique pour acheter des caramels
alors il discutait il fouilla dans leur
poche et puis au dernier moment ils se
sont aperçus qu'il leur manquait quelque
chose d'important oui de très important
et ce qui leur manquait et bien c'était
moi voilà tout simplement alors tu vois
ce que je veux dire je crois que j'ai
une petite idée et mes enfants cette
fois ci je pense que vous ne m'aurez pas
coincé à bohars oui on doit c'était
facile tout quand est ce que je suis ben
moi je pense que tu es tout simplement
un rond heroes les ronds dans l'eau etc
tu m'as parlé de tout ça tout à leur
héros héron petit patapon 4 po moi je
crois que tu es un rond tout simplement
je pense que bell bell était un rond de
serviette c'est ça fat man et enfin nous
le moron qui remplace l'argent mais pas
dans les soutes une façon fait un petit
peu familière c'était je n'ai plus de
ronger d'argent voilà c'était ça pousse
moussu oui c'était ça c'est déjà ça
alors cette fois-ci mes enfants j'ai
gagné et will plus fort gagne ils
peuvent renoncer
je t'attends tu
[Musique]
attendais le thé le zoo de pouce beauté
et je vais regarder deboos pas de vous
parler d'un corpus cas merci 5 merci
alors nous à nous à new fabris oui tu as
vu mon ami puis quand vous la vie c'est
le jeu de pouce messieurs alors c'est à
nous gens meurent alors tu vas au
tableau b au tableau
y a pas oublié ton marqueur je vois là
ah bon très bien pas trop difficile et
trop n'ont pas trop difficile
alors c'est un mot en neuf lettres
oui quand même quand même quand même ne
leur convient pas c'est pas difficile
la première 1 1
voilà alors ces petites plaies 3 4 5 6 7
pour les manques et la dernière bien
voilà je suis sûr que c'est un animal en
bas alors dit si tu commence comme ça
moi je te connais tu adores les animaux
alors tu me fais plein chez les gens
c'est vrai mais j'adore les animaux
tiens tu as raison à
c'est un animal qui rampe oh non non non
non pas du coût économique au cours des
fois si court quand même un petit peu
enfin c'est pas à sa princesse que la
caps pat non non pas qu'à pâques à la
pâte
il vole pas heaven wii et qui vole très
haut mais il vole très haut ah oui bon
niveau les vols enfin est-ce que c'est
un très gros oiseau au nom en haut et
les moyens et moi si joli a il est joli
oui oui
de très jolies plumes à
elana elle dit c'est un oiseau que l'on
trouve dans nos régions au oui oui oui
veux tu que je te donne la troisième
lettre bah oui je veux dire la troisième
c'est un elle ce que tu sais des oiseaux
y en a beaucoup et rihanna alors et là
c'est un oiseau qu'on rencontre partout
ltd et louis il vole très haut alors
attends une petite seconde parce que
[Musique]
tu m'a dit qu'il y avait combien de
lettres neuf lettres
remettre ça colle pas du tout avec ce
que j'ai trouvé moi passionné qu'est ce
que tu as trouvé j'aurais pensé comme ça
alouettes mais oui mais l alouette
gentille alouette bon enfin pouces conçu
comment se fait-il que nous trouvions à
la 3e et rahel mais parce que ça s'écrit
à deux ailes aux us de théo bon alors
j'ai compris il me reste à rectifier
binger alouettes bah tu penses regard
qu'on porte à elle aurait eu
deux thés ou est ce que tu as vu deux
ailes à ba2 elle c'est normal pour un
oiseau entendu c'est normal
je trouve c'est écrit comme ça au touch
l'ont tué cc c'est très difficile tu
peux être honteux ya pas deux mais oui
bah oui c'est rare que je trompe tout le
temps tu sais pas je suis désespéré
toucan grand qu'est ce que nie en transe
moi je savais pas aussi exactement comme
pouces moussu ah oui d'ailleurs je ne
suis pas certain pourquoi est ce qui
aurait pas de zèle alouettes dutouya
qu'un seul l alouette ping willows
écoute-moi écoute pas que tu sais oui tu
sais pourquoi elle ne va jamais se
percher sur les armes l'alouette et bien
tout simplement parce qu'elle ne peut
pas elle a un gros ongles à la pâte et
qu'il empêche de le faire alors elle
marche elle court elle vole elle vole
très haut même âge que les ducs à leur
elle vole très haut mais elle ne se pose
pas sur les arbres voilà à quoi ça je ne
le savais pas à ma poste monsieur
georges et volé près d'une alouette à la
volée par du grenelle où elle est
soignée par tous étaient
contents à bord ce qui
n'est pas sérieux
heureusement que j'appelle belle qui
elle reste toujours extrêmement dignes
et vos relevés yon laval
la twa fabrice vial jouer avec moi là là
c'est pas si la musique tubes et ça
tombait bien car c'est dans ces moments
[Musique]
que tu que tu essaies les gants belbel
que tu t'ai entendu dire que j'étais
digne ah oui c'est vrai trafic toujours
très chic quartier apprécient maclas à
oui c'est vrai et à propos de classe on
fait notre petite classe musicale je
suis prêt et tu te souviennes notre
petit j'aimais oui bien sûr alors vous
écoutez attentivement bell bell est
lorsqu elle remplace des syllabes par un
bruit ou quelque chose comme ça par un
fonds par exemple par exemple font que
je remplace ainsi la part la note qui
correspond très exactement à ce qui
manque dans le mot choisi par bessat et
à la fin toutes ces notes formeront le
début d'une chanson oui tout le monde
connaît d'accord alors je vais raconter
l'histoire de la chanson c'est une
histoire qui va nous obliger à nous
élever de quelques mètres au dessus du
droit du sol
c'est une histoire d'oiseaux une
histoire qui nous vient d'un autre pays
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique un pays
froid qui est près de la pop star
alaska à la cac
voilà mais l'oiseau lui bien de chez
nous c'est un oiseau coup rencontre très
souvent paris
par ici par ici
oui ce n'est pas une totale ça n'est pas
non plus tout cas qu et ça n'est pas un
rognon
1 renault a géré dire un rossignol
a qu'un pas que c'est oiseaux on lui
fait subir un curieux traitement tu
trouve d'ailleurs comme on ne voit
jamais attraper les oiseaux ou alors on
devrait tout de suite l'hérault compte
chez
on devrait tout de suite héros
chez les relâcher cet astucieux alors
non une histoire non seulement ils le
gardent cet oiseau mais encore il va
racheter toutes les plumes cette pauvre
petit pote qui peut plus voler ni se
protéger de la pluie
bay
ne pleure pas rapide on scellera leur
histoire je pense que c'est du soleil
n'est ce pas in du soleil voilà et alors
ils risquent d'attraper une grave map10
bas l'année mais tu es très fort tout
c'est très méchant je t'assure que
lorsque j'ai entendu cette chanson pour
la première fois j'étais stupéfaite j'en
ai vu d'autres autres chandelles aussi
comme si selon elle des parfums je me
suis dit il faut trouver une solution
une solution une solution s'est fait
demander à fabrice
comment faire pour le titre de là le
tirer de là s'est pas fait maintenant il
te reste à lire les notes que tu as
place ici bon alors nous avons sol la
sicile à sol la si sol près ce qui se
joue bas ce qui se
ah non les moins joué
ces alouette alouette
oui
j'oubliais il est à huy est toujours en
région mabri souvenirs de presse abri
scott se voudrait loup garou jean
antunes jouera contre le très bon peuple
belge arrive
[Musique]
est à tapis
déjà papa papa d'amy de 4
ans qui fait que la vie majeur s'est
désisté et rzeszow fait des choses mais
comme je n'y pas de mine war n'est bon
qu'à faire attention les quatre amis
sont descendus dit les caps a mis son de
retard izem amis
et
m
mais pour jouer aujourd'hui et
[Musique]
vouloir devenir amis